people 55 and older with an underlying  health condition are now eligible to get  the vaccine  but you can't go to a mega site you have  to get your vaccine at a retail pharmacy  like smith's and cvs  the state says it is to ensure a  pharmacist is on site  to review your medical history and talk  about potential complications  the underlying health issues in this new  directive include asthma  cancer high blood pressure dementia and  other factors including smokers  you do not have to show documentation  proving a health condition  if you need help making or even  cancelling a covid vaccine appointment  you can call the number there on your  screen it is available 8 am to 8 pm  7 days a week we have all this  information for you on 8newsnow.com